organised by the constituents he
represented
together they remembered
a week on since the david amos death he
remains at the forefront of the minds of
so many i'm here today i have respect
for him
and horror this has happened
and dreadfully sorry for his wife and
his lovely family every time i wake up
it hits you
that it's um
this man has what he's done for south
end and lee
has
had this done to him what's this week
been like for this town it's been
particularly for the local
area it's it's been very hard
you see a lot of people walking around
and still in shock of what's going on
this row of businesses stand meters from
the church where sir david died they
won't be forgetting the man who always
used to stop and say hello he would
always be there
to help us yeah
christmas won't be the same here because
every christmas
literally a week before christmas he
turns appears he
judges all the christmas windows for the
shops
and awards like first second third prize
to
the windows
in the parade and he personally does it
himself
the messages and flowers from across
south end and beyond fill his office
many are now questioning how safe they
are in here
since the david amos death the security
of mps and their staff has been in the
spotlight just how exposed they are
outside the palace of westminster now
mps are being urged to take up the offer
of security guards at their constituency
surgeries but they'll have to find a
balance between staying approachable and
being safe
the man charged with the mp's murder
appeared at the old bailey via video
link he is next due in court on the 7th
of march
in south end the silence signifies the
respect they shared for their member of
parliament
fondly remembered as simply being one of
them ashnahara nags sky news in lyon
city